dire qui un programme chargé et
important et juste après tes P il y aura
bien sûr bienvenue au monastère avec
sœur Catherine qu'on aimait Fabien Cara
ne le manquez pas merci d'avoir été avec
nous les chéris je voulais vous
remercier on vous retrouve ce soir et
j'adore quand vous venez franchement qu
merci beaucoup pour vre des
amours on va voir l'extrait de math qui
s'estadressait notamment à Pascal pro
mais apparemment elle nous met dans le
voilà Pascal pro et moi donc elle
s'estadressa à nous Mathide Panau et
bien écoutez voilà on va voir son son
message en tout cas il y a des gros
moyens de bénisse la
prode Monsieur Pascal Pro vous mentez
puisque j'ai bien dormi dans le
campement la raison de cette polémique
c'est que vous ne voulez pas parler des
morts à la rue c'est que les médias
aujourd'hui ne veulent pas que on parle
des personnes qui sont sans abri veulent
que en quelque sorte les gens pauvres
meurent en silence et bien Monsieur
Pascal pro je vous lance un défi invitz
sur votre plateau une personne sans
abris du campement de sol ferino je vous
invite juste à faire juste une nuit ce
que moi j'ai fait c'est-à-dire d'aller
dormir dehors dans des conditions où
nous savons nous que derrière nous nous
retrouvons avec une douche
chaude alors elle est incroyableelle
elle a été dormir une un
soir on dirait qu'elle a fait non mais
on dirait qu'elle a fait un truc de fou
on dirait qu'elle elle a grimpé les
vraestes non mais sans rigoler mais math
panneau mais quel ridicule mais quelle
ridicule une fois de plus à chaque fois
qu'elle prend la parole elle se
ridiculise à chaque fois que ces gensl
prennent la parole ils se ridiculisent
c'est les Gill Verdez c'est incroyable
excusez-moi de vous dire ça c'est les
dignes dignes vraiment les dignes
héritiers de Gilles
Verdez inviter sur vos plateau des des
gens qui souffrent c'est ce qu'on
rent et Pascal fait beaucoup plus je
pense que la France insoumise aussi de
je lui propose de regarder t PMP
régulièrement parce qu' elle verra
qu'onite n pas cité je pense que c'est
pour ça je pense qu'ils ont dit ouais
attention parce qu'ils font ils font
souvent des truc mais tout monde fait
des truc math pan déjà je v dire c'est
une responsable politique donc les
responsables politiques déjà leur but
dans la vie ça doit être que euh la vie
soit meilleure pour leurs concitoyens
euh voilà donc déjà elle c'est un
exploit qu'ell veuilleent que leur la
vie soit meilleure pour les Français
c'est un exp alors c'est juste son
boulot hein on lui a rien demandé
d'autre malheureusement elle a dit quand
on sera au pouvoir malheureusement Bti
Panau excusez-moi de vous dire ça mais
je pense que franchement vous ne serez
jamais au pouvoir matine pano surtout
avec un chef comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui est caramélisé euh voilà je vous dis
donc là vous dis déjà moi aussi je peux
dire si et avec des si euh on aurait
plus àidalgo à Paris euh donc voilà donc
je vous le dis donc j'ai les
commentaires en dessous elle se fait
déchirer bien sûr mais c'est normal qu'
see déchirer mais quel part se fait
déchirer normal parce que c'est pas
juste un point c'est quand elle dit la
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 plus
de SDF c'est le seul truc où elle a
raison vrai c'est pas
normal0000 person 7e puissance du monde
il y a encore des SDF c'est tout après
tout le reste elle est complètement à
côté on ira un par un on ira un par un
visiter des SDF la nuit c'est pas
Disneyland les SDF on tourne pas tour de
dit oui les plateaux télé au lie d'être
sur les plateau tél mais vous aussi vous
y êtes sur les P vous aussi ils vont
quand ils vont chez BFM ils vont chez
qui chez la baé piierre non le patron de
BFM c'est qui quand ils vont sur LCI
c'est pas la bépierre non plus c'est qui
le patron de LCI pourtant il ils y vont
là-bas ils y vont faire leur show au
plateau télé quand il tweet Twitter
c'est qui le patron de Twitter donc ils
sont bien malin avec leur leçons moi je
suis d'accord avec eux que sur le truc
il y a il y a des SDF c'est pas normal
en France c'est pas normal on devrait
pas en être là en 2024 mais quand je les
entends parler des plateaux télé vous y
êtes tout le temps fourré le patron de
BFM je suis désolé qu'est-ce qui c'est
pas c'est pas un mec qui est SMIC donc
faut arrêter de de dire n'importe quoi
et les tweets c'est El musk les tweet
c'est c'est qui Twitter c'est mus arrête
de vous servir aussi d' muskors c'est El
musk
pas en
anglais à côté leur truc d'aller visiter
des SDF tous les soirs chacun are tour
arrêtez ça sert à rien c'est pas c'est
pas un club de vacances on fait pas ça
non mais elle dit la vie c'est pas
plateaux de télévision mais c'est pas
non plus les
tantesit déjà renvoyer dans les cordes y
a 2 ans à l'assemblé nation it peu près
le même numéro mais le gouvernement lui
a rappelé que ils ont créé entre 130 et
200000 lit donc il y a quand même des
choses qui ont été faites donc mais bien
sû c'est pas ass il y a 300000 SDF a
200000 lit c'est évidemment pas ass mais
c'est
mieux tout fa dans
nul 2 voilà
N faire plaisir
de a l'insoumis de l'insou fa dire la
vérité et bien parler de tous les faits
pour que on sache c'estd que elle quand
tu dis qu'il faut réquisitionner des
casernes oui mais oui non mais je suis
d'accord avec toi mais en fait ils l'ont
fait en face d'un immeuble qui est
complètement vide et l'idée c'était de
parler du fait que faudrait
réquisitionner faudrait réquisitionner
des
endroitsp c'est là qu'ils ont rien
compris l'immeubleimmeuble il appartient
à quelquun il appartient à ququ coûte
une fortune l'IM tu
crois av fait un truc intelligent il fer
des manif pourqu les casernes douchout
dans la France des
cas nous
propose
chèouraiment que ce
soit
pour ou Hugo manos vous croyez quoi mec
l'immeuble il va faire ça c'est la même
c'est la même histoire que dire on va
taxer tous les riches comme ça on sera
tranquille exact mais mec mec me on ve
on veut on veut on veut des vraies
solutions c'est des solutions à l'
portepièces qui ne veut rien dire et qui
ne servent à rien qui sont impossibles
donc une fois de plus math Panau dit
d'énormes conneries comme comme voilà
comme d'habitude voilà demander au
gouvernement de réquisitionner des
endroits qui sont de la fonction
publique qui servent à rien c'est ça
c'est une idée ça c'est une vraie idé
met des millions militaires avant moi
j'ai fait l'armée il y avait des
casernes il y a des douches il y a des
cantines il y a tout dans les casernes
et des casernesout dans la France
qu'elle dit n'importe quoi prendre un
immeuble osmanien ça n'arrivera jamais
arrêtez voz pas qu'elle dit n'importe
quo elle dit vous dites n'importe quoi
madame pano vous dites n'importe quoi
comme d'habitude il n'y a que des
bêtises qui sortent de votre bouche
c'est incroyable qu'est-ce qu'il veut et
des mensonges B si je peux m'expliquer
une seconde ou mais tu oui mais tu vas
saouler tout le monde mais c'est pas
grave si c'était que des bêtises énorme
connerie mais jeaime beaucoup Ron il a
pas dit une énorme connerie dire le seul
qui dit lei en pourcentage de conneries
je pense que tu es très loin
deusemoi bah toi c'est une une phrase h
conneries donc il t'a peut-être rattrapé
mais ça bien qu' m'explique où j'ai dit
moi aussi si je peux je t'explique
réquisition des logements vides des
logements privés VI c'est une
revendication de la gauche depuis
extrêmement
longtemps mais toi imima bienir ou
marche laiss finir laiss
C il y a des imbles spéculatif comme
celuil qui est reconnu comme tel qui
sont quasiment vid ou vid et quand ils
sont occupés c'est que des Airbnb voilà
Paris
aujourd'hui
mais mais mais qu'est-ce que ça chant
qu' soit tu crois vraiment que le
propriétaire de l'immeuble il veut il va
vous le prêter mais vous tuouoi mais
c'est pas ça c'est pas le prêt ça
s'appelle de la
réquisition il y a de plus en plus de
logements vid à
Paris la répondre laisse-moi lui
répondre laisse-moi répondre que je dis
des conneries avec mes casernes ok
focalis
focalisneries vous êtes focalisé sur
Paris les SDF c'est que à Paris ou c'est
partout en France il é à Paris il éta à
Paris qu-ce que je reproche il reste à
Paris à Solferino dans le 7e
[Musique]
arrondissement j'aimerais lui parler
comment tu fais pour la France mais tu
dis des choses qui sont impossibles tu
tu dis tu dis des trucs qui sont bêtes
sont débil vous avez dit changer la vie
des
gens tatoi tais-toi tais-toi arrête un
peu tu dis n'importe quoi moi ce que je
veux quand je dis on va changer la vie
des gens je veux des trucs possibles tu
sais très bien que ça c'est impossible
tu veux faire quoi tous les mecs alors
il y a plus un mec qui va les me le mec
tu crois vraiment qu' va dire ou
de nous parler des lois mais là il y a
une loi est propriétaire de de
l'immeuble c'est la loi pourquoi
tuquisition ça veut dire
cher
tu ch respecter les lois il veut jamais
changer les
loisec un armurier se fait agresser par
TR
gar de
PO des guignoles qui sont défendus par
un
guignol on veut des choses qui soitible
elle dit n'importe quoi comme tous leur
programme c'est n'importe quoi la
plupart du temps et toi tu plonges comme
un que tu es regarde-moi ça allez on
vaétendre un
peui au moin lui au moins ber c'est
quelqu'un de
bien on est
voilà la monarchie britannique la
monarchie
britannique d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je
vais le faire
lundi
dire